皆さんはオデッセイと英学ご存知でしょうか実は私ですね先日オデッセイの試写会の方
に参加させていただきまして
5わせ先にオデッセイの映画見させていただきましたよかった
マジでよく主人公はそんな宇宙飛行士なんですよ河川の探索みたいな関節とか西の方に
切っちゃってて稼い丁寧にこうね天候がすぐか
やりやすくていきなり即すんごい風が強く安定していろんなことが起きちゃって主人公
だけちょっと加瀬に取り残されちゃうんですおいてかれて
タッピングこないかもしれないですよそんな授業で金はどのようにして稼いで
生き延びるが僕の方な感想なんですけども
あのすごい職別医学を学びたくなりました主人公の後に
ショット別学を専攻してるんですのカフェ
の土を使ってあこれ以上を楽しみだよく家庭というマイナス手こずる5度の寒異空間で
彼が何もないところで生き延びてや素晴らしいな
俺も素晴らしいだろ僕ねーわねまぁはとにぐらいの力あると思ってね米亞洲子という
言葉でといけないんですけども寒い厳しい環境でも多分僕は生き延びてると思うよ特に
役立つものがおいていない場所に僕はと事故
られて生活してみようと思いますきっと俺なら生き延びれるそう
助けが来るまでよ
ん
これが今回の連動口がレストランの裏とかにある本格的なやつから課税名前250ごと
に対しこの冷凍庫は-35
余裕だー
くれよああああ
というわけで僕はこうがーここで生活してみます風に比べると全然楽やまで大丈夫で
あああったところにかっぺいトビルガー
どの店坂村がつけないんですけど
わけじゃないよーあーこんな動画でいろんなお手を出した事が
これは書はを制圧です多分
気がおきますすみとかポッ
これ
六花荘どす間ずっとのかと2ぽいやってなるのでこれぞとちょっと入れましょう
そうだないと言います proguard 仕方ああよくわからないそうだ
米までちょっと友達に聞いてみますうわぁ0
わー
ano
ブーバーした
を行っていますうん
次はああ
住まいや砂ああ
ああああああ
この a のを果たせていません
そうでしたーーで講演どろろの入れフィットに綺麗なで作ってるかも知れませんん
ああああああああああああ
動画がジャガー
none
何年の皆さんずつ動かしての感謝祭が持って ok ok
ここすごい本当にずれ込んでいるあ今や企業
ますすみとか企業この導入設定するとか覚えてるねこんなの使う
ああああああ
結果をさせますやった要素を待ってもらっちゃおう
wh
ポッに欲しい関係者を吸っていません
これ付けあるんですけど
を取っちゃんって
知りません
delorean
taipei ん
wii u を反映してきて
ログいつも結構溜まってきました weblog 発射できる
ちょっと名前です
ni
飛んでもったい上映
wh
ore ni
w boku wa dare
yeah
あ
僕はも某泣きすることで何撮ってきたのでぜひ皆さんも知ってほしいと思う値よります
でで全部今ですね今ならキャンペーンでオデッセイのじゃんこういう植物1盗んでくる
みたいです
塾たぶん今前提やに飲んでるなため農学部とか植物油多くのことを学びたいと思って
いるくらいなんですけども
植物が育ってるんじゃボディステイプラントっていうのはあるみたいねぇよ俺なんかで
くれて自分でもらえる
欲しいのでこれ育ててみたいと思って動画の説明欄から詳しい情報があるのでぜひ
そちらからチェックしてみてください
じゃん
war
def